>> ALL RIGHT.
IT’S RARE FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO INTERVENE
IN INDIVIDUAL COMMERCE, BUT THE
FACT THAT HE DID AND ORDERED ALL
MEAT PLANTS TO STAY OPEN DURING
WHAT HAS BEEN A DISRUPTED SUPPLY
DEBATE, ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE
NATION’S BEEF LARGELY THE
MIDWEST IOWA HAS NOW BEEN FROZEN
IN PLACE BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH WORKERS GETTING CORONAVIRUS
IN A NUMBER OF FACILITIES, NOT
ONLY THERE, BUT SOUTH DAKOTA AND
OTHER STATES AS WELL.
IOWA GOVERNOR REYNOLDS IS WITH
US RIGHT NOW.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK.
HOW DID YOU FEEL WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S ORDER TO GET THESE
OPERATIONS OPEN?
>> YEAH, WELL, THANK YOU, NEIL.
IT’S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU AGAIN.
I APPRECIATE ORDER THAT HE PUT
IN PLACE AND WE’RE COLLECTIVELY
WORKING WITH OUR PROCESSING
PLANTS.
WE’VE BEEN IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION WITH OVER 40
MANUFACTURERS AND PROCESSING
PLANTS TO MAKE SURE WE’RE
WORKING WITH THEM TO DO
ADDITIONAL TESTING, TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE PPE.
TO MAKE SURE THEY’RE DOING--
PUTTING THE EFFORTS IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THEY’RE PROTECTING
THEIR WORK FORCE AS WELL SO WE
CAN KEEP THE SUPPLY OF FOOD
MOVING THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
IOWA PRODUCES 10% OF THE FOOD
SUPPLY AND WE’RE A FOURTH OF THE
PROCESSING IN THE STATE OF IOWA
AND SO THIS IS A CRITICAL AND AN
ESSENTIAL WORK FORCE AND A
CRITICAL AND ESSENTIAL WORK
PRODUCTION CAPABILITY.
SO WE’RE WORKING IN TANDEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP THE
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN MOVING AND
KEEPING AMERICA FED.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, THAT WORK FORCE
THOUGH, MANY OF THEM ARE VERY
NERVOUS, EVEN TYSON FOOD EARLIER
ON SAID IT’S ONLY GOING TO KEEP
ABOUT 20% OF ITS FACILITY OPEN
BEFORE THIS PRESIDENTIAL ORDER.
A LOT OF THOSE WORKERS FEEL
THEY’RE BEING FORCED TO GO BACK
UNDER DANGEROUS CONDITIONS.
ARE THEY?
>> YEAH, SO THIS IS WHY I THINK
THE TESTING HAS REALLY BEEN
CRITICAL TO THIS AND WE HAVE
DONE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TESTING JUST IN THE LAST WEEK
WORKING WITH OUR FACILITIES.
WE’VE TESTED OVER 7500, THE
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING OF THE
EMPLOYEES AND THEN AS WELL AS
WE’VE DONE THE SIROLOGY TESTING
WITH OVER 5,000 AND WE HAVE
SCHEDULED 12,000 TESTS OF BOTH
THE DIAGNOSTIC AND THE SIROLOGY
TESTING THE WEEK AND A HALF.
THIS GIVES THE EMPLOYEES THE
CONFIDENCE THEY NEED TO FEEL
SAFE IN RETURNING BACK TO WORK
WITH THE PROPER PPE, AS WELL AS
THE CONDITIONS IN THE FACILITY.
AND THEY’RE DOING A LOT OF THAT,
THEY’RE DOING THE TESTING AS
THEY COME IN TO CHECK THE
TEMPERATURE.
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE THE PPE,
DOING AS MUCH SEPARATION AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING AS POSSIBLE,
BUT REALLY, I THINK, OUR ABILITY
TO GET IN THERE AND WORK WITH
THE FACILITIES AND DO THE
TESTING TO REALLY IDENTIFY AND
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF THE
VIRUS AND THE VIRUS ACTIVITY
TAKING PLACE IN THE FACILITY.
WE CAN ISOLATE THEM, GET THEM ON
A ROAD TO RECOVERY.
IDENTIFY WHO IS TESTING NEGATIVE
AND MAYBE SEPARATE THE TWO,
SEPARATE THE WORK FORCE IN ORDER
TO REALLY PROTECT THOSE THAT
HAVE NOT TESTED POSITIVE.
SO, THAT’S REALLY BEEN A
CRITICAL COMPONENT, I THINK, OF
US CONTINUING TO GET THE
FACILITIES UP AND GOING AND TO
KEEP THEM UP AND PROCESSING AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC.
NEIL: YOU ARE OPENING SLOWLY
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE, I
BELIEVE, RESTAURANTS FIRST OFF,
ALBEIT AT 50% CAPACITY.
I THINK SALONS, LARGE
GATHERINGS, AMUSEMENT PARKS PUT
OFF UNTIL AT LEAST THE MIDDLE OF
MAY.
IS THAT WHERE THINGS STAND NOW?
>> YES, IT DOES.
WE’VE EASED RESTRICTIONS IN 77
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND SEEING 88
TO 90% OF OUR POSITIVITY CASES
IN THE 22 COUNTIES THAT WILL
REMAIN UNDER THE HIGHER LEVEL,
AND THAT PHASE ONE.
WE OPENED UP AT 50% CAPACITY,
RETAIL, FITNESS CENTERS, MALLS
AND IN PHASE TWO WE HOPE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT SALONS AND BARBER
SHOPS, CONTINUING TO OPEN UP AND
BRING MORE BUSINESSES BACK ON.
YOU KNOW, IN IOWA WE HAD OVER
80% OF OUR WORK FORCE THAT WAS
ESSENTIAL WORK -- THAT QUALIFIED
UNDER ESSENTIAL WORK FORCE, SO
WE HAD A RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT
OF BUSINESSES THAT WERE SHUT
DOWN, BUT STILL, IT’S HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE’RE OPENING THEM
BACK UP, BUT DOING IT IN A SAFE
AND RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
IOWANS ARE RESPONSIBLE AND
THEY’RE PRACTICING PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL AS OUR
BUSINESSES SO WE’RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE DATA,
MONITOR THE VIRUS ACTIVITY.
WE’RE ABLE TO DO THAT FROM A
STATE WIDE PERSPECTIVE TO A
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE TO A COUNTY
AND A ZIP CODE SO WE WILL HAVE A